next week we're doing some shows from
Miami and JD's coming down and the funny
thing is so blitt wants to take JD
Speedo shopping for any bathing suits
when's that happening JD it's not
happening I'm not going to you guys no
it's the greatest thing I ever heard we
need to get JD the perfect Speedo I'm
not I don't need a speedo dude stop
trust me when you get it on right and
it's the right size you're gonna love
your body no I don't love my body now
and I'm not I'm not gonna love it then I
can't wait to see the right one yeah no
there's no you know what God damn you
Blake you're such an [__] so Sal had
this idea for Miami that I thought was
sort of [__] weird and he's he's dead
set on doing it we kind of rejected it
but I'm thinking it through he's bro we
had five writers meetings about going to
Miami and South more than that yeah well
the five that I was in so I'll brought
it up he's dead set on this he Sal wants
to go to the nude beach and he wants to
put some bread in his ass and see if
seagulls will eat it
um
with him I don't
I think I want to see that I would see
that for sure well guess what's gonna
happen to Sal what they're not gonna
just choose the bread you think they got
that much accuracy yeah seagulls of
course no no they're gonna be pecking
around
no yeah it'll be fine I'll stand there
and laugh I wanted to stick I wanted to
line french fries up uh Howard in the
crack of my ass I like line up six or
seven and see how many uh uh seagulls
will eat yeah well Robin's got a point
well this is what we were all saying
that made me these birds might think his
[__] is a worm and eat that
nobody's eating that thing not even a
bird but I spoke to a wildlife expert
Howard
he said you might just get a few
scratches that's about it he goes you
won't get hurt yeah I think you'll be
all right because first of all you'll be
laying on your belly right right so your
[__] and balls will be covered exactly
and I'll just show like food in my ass
go the birds on you
foreign